♪ ♪
>> IF THEY RAN A SPY RING OR
INFORMANT RING AND THEY WERE
PAYING PEOPLE WITHIN THE TRIM
CAMPAIGN, IF ANY OF THAT IS
TRUE, THAT'S AN ABSOLUTE
REDLINE.
>> THIS CLAIM BY THE PRESIDENT,
SUGGESTION BY GIULIANI THAT
THERE'S A POLITICAL SPY EMBEDDED
IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IS
NONSENSE.
SPEAK WITH THE PRESIDENT I THINK
IT'S GRATEFUL THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING T
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING O
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING H
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING V
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING E
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING T
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING I
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING S
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING E
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING T
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING R
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING G
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING N
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING R
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING L
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING O
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GOING K
INTO IT AND DETERMINE AND ENSURE
THAT THERE WAS NO SURVEILLANCE
DONE FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES
AGAINST OUR CAMPAIGN.
>> Bret: THIS IS THE TALK.
WHAT IS THE DEAL WITH THE
INVESTIGATION?
THE PRESIDENT SAYING THESE
REPORTS OF THE SPINE, INFORMANT
INSIDE THE CAMPAIGN, HE WANTS TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
TODAY MEETING WITH THE FBI
DIRECTOR, DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE DAN COATS, WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT WAS IN THE MEANING BUT
WE WERE TOLD HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT THIS.
DOJ PUT OUT A STATEMENT SAYING
THAT THEY ARE ASKING FOR AN
ONGOING REVIEW OF THE FISA
APPLICATION PROCESS TO INCLUDE
DETERMINING WHETHER THERE WAS
IMPROPRIETY OR POLITICAL
MOTIVATION AND HOW THE FBI
CONDUCTED ITS
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
PERSON SUSPECTED OF INVOLVEMENT
WITH RUSSIAN AGENTS WHO
INTERFERED IN THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL WILL
CONDUCT A APPROPRIATE, CONSULT
THE APPROPRIATE U.S. ATTORNEY IF
THERE'S ANY EVIDENCE OF
POTENTIAL CRIMINAL CONDUCT.
ROSENSTEIN SAYING, "IF ANYONE
DID INFILTRATE OUR SURVEIL
PARTICIPANTS IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN FOR INAPPROPRIATE
PURPOSES, WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
IT AND TAKE APPROPRIATE ACTION."
LET'S BRING THE PANEL FROM
WASHINGTON.
JONAH GOLDBERG, SENIOR EDITOR AT
NATIONAL REVIEW.
A.B. STODDARD, ASSOCIATE EDITOR
AT REAL CLEAR POLITICS.
KATIE PAVLICH, TownHall.com.
JONAH, THIS SEEMED TO PICK UP
STEAM AND WAS FUELED BY THE
PRESIDENT'S TWEET ABOUT THIS.
THE FACT THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL IS TAKING IT,
WHAT DOES IT TELL US?
>> TELLS US THERE'S CREDIBLE
REASON TO TAKE A HARDER LOOK AT
WHAT WAS GOING ON IN 2016 IN
TERMS OF THE INVESTIGATION OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AT THE SAME TIME, I THINK THE
TALK ABOUT THIS GUY, AS FAR AS
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT A SPY
EMBEDDED IN THE CAMPAIGN IS
HYPERBOLE.
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH PEOPLE
ABOUT THEIR CONTACTS WITH RUSSIA
THAN WE KNOW ABOUT IS NOT AN
INVENTED SPY.
MAYBE IT'S AN INFORMANT BUT IT'S
NOT QUITE WHAT PEOPLE ARE MAKING
IT OUT TO BE FEARED THAT KEYWORD
OR KEY PHRASE IN ROSENSTEIN
STATEMENT WAS "FOR ANY
INAPPROPRIATE PURPOSE."
THERE IS AMPLE REASON THAT THEY
MAYBE SHOULD'VE LOOKED INTO
RUSSIAN COLLUSION OR SUSPICION
OF IT.
IF THERE WAS OTHER REASONS WHY
THEY WERE DOING IT, IF THEY WERE
TRYING TO UNDO OR HURT
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR IF THERE IS
REASON TO BELIEVE THERE WAS
POLITICAL MOTIVATION, THAT WOULD
BE VERY BAD AND IT'S WORTH
LOOKING INTO.
>> Bret: KATIE, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> IT'S A GOOD THING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS WILLING TO LOOK AT
THIS FURTHER.
BUMPING INTO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL IS PRUDENT
GIVEN THAT THE PEOPLE INVOLVED,
POTENTIAL MISUSE OR ABUSE OF
POWER DURING THE 2016 ELECTION,
STILL WORKING INSIDE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ARE AT THE FBI.
INSPECTOR GENERAL DOESN'T HAVE
JURISDICTION TO INTERVIEW
POLITICAL EMPLOYEES WHO WORKED
IN THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHO
MAY NOW BE GONE.
I WOULD GET BACK TO THE NOISE
SURROUNDING THE ISSUE COMES DOWN
TO WHAT LAUNCHED THE SPECIAL
COASTAL OF THE FIRST PLACE.
WHETHER THERE WERE LEGAL
INSTANCES OF AUTHORITY BEING
ABUSED IN THE 2016 CAMPAIGN FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES.
THE QUESTION IS, YOU LOOK AT
WHEN THE INVESTIGATION HAPPENED,
AFTER THE HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN INVESTIGATION WRAPPED
UP, THEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS
ALLEGEDLY GETTING -- AND
INFORMANT WAS GIVING INFORMATION
TO THE FBI.
IF IT WAS REALLY JUST ABOUT
RUSSIAN SURVEILLANCE AND
INTERFERENCE IN THE ELECTION,
THEN WHY DID THE INVESTIGATION
STARTED EARLIER IN 2015 WHEN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION KNEW ABOUT
RUSSIA'S PLANS TO BATTLE IN THE
ELECTIONS.
>> Bret: HERE IS DEVIN NUNES
TALKING ABOUT TRYING TO GET THE
DOCUMENTATION.
>> WE ARE ASKING FOR THE
DOCUMENTATION THAT YOU USED IT
TO THE INVESTIGATION.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF WHAT ELSE WAS USED IN
THAT FISA BECAUSE YOU HAVE MANY
PEOPLE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WERE CLAIMING THAT WE
ARE WRONG.
IF WE ARE WRONG, SHOW US THE
INFORMATION.
>> Bret: WE ARE TOLD A JUDGE
HAS RECEIVED ABOUT CAPITOL HILL
HAS NOT.
>> BRET, IT'S A BATTLE ABOUT
SEPARATION OF POWERS AND WHAT
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS CAN
DO IN THEIR OVERSIGHT ROLES
DIVORCE DOCUMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND WHICH
DOCUMENTS, AFTER ROD ROSENSTEIN
HAS GIVEN MANY, MANY, MANY
DOCUMENTS, HE IS RESISTING
PROVIDING THE REPUBLICAN MEMBERS
OF THE HOUSE ON THE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A STRUGGLE TO DEFINE
WHAT IS WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF
OVERSIGHTS AND WHAT IS
OVERREACH.
I HAVE SPOKEN TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THE FBI
MIGHT'VE CONDUCTED THE
HILLARY CLINTON INVESTIGATION
BUT STILL SAY YOU CAN'T SHARE
RAW INTELLIGENCE FROM AN
INVESTIGATION THAT COULD BE
PROVIDED TO THE WITNESSES.
TODAY YOU HAD DNI, FBI, EVERYONE
HUDDLING WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND RUDY GIULIANI WHO WAS ON A
P.R. CAMPAIGN DEMANDING THAT HE
CAN'T SIT FOR AN INTERVIEW WITH
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL UNLESS WE
KNOW ABOUT OTHER WITNESSES THAT
WERE REVEALED IN A
"NEW YORK TIMES" STORY THIS
WEEKEND.
YOU CAN'T DEMAND THAT YOU BE
GIVEN INFORMATION ON A WITNESS
IN EXCHANGE FOR TALKING TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
HE SAYS THE MEETING TODAY IN
WHICH THE DEMANDS FOR THE
DOCUMENTS ARE BEING MADE, HE WAS
DOING THAT IN HIS CAPACITY NOT
AS A SUBJECT OF THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION BUT AS PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES TO MAKE
SURE THAT CONGRESS IS GETTING
WHAT THEY NEED FROM THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THEY ARE DOING A REALLY, REALLY
GOOD JOB OF MUDDYING AND THIS
P.R. CAMPAIGN WHAT IS AND ISN'T
ALLOWED AND WHAT IS AND ISN'T
APPROPRIATE.
IT'S A HUGE BATTLE THAT'S
DRAWING OUT ON BOTH SIDES BUT
THE PRESIDENT AND RUDY GIULIANI
AND DEVIN NUNES ARE TRYING TO
MAKE IT APPEAR THAT
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT, MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
EVERY SINGLE DOCUMENT.
THE TRUTH IS THEY DON'T.